Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Vous êtes sûr que vous allez parfois
à la pharmacie ?
(Rires)
Vous êtes sûr que vous arrivez
à lire le nom des médicaments ?
Parce que moi, j'ai eu du mal au début.
Spiramycine metronidazole.
Amoxicilline-acide clavulanique.
Complètement imprononçable.
Barbare.
Mais ne vous plaignez pas parce que
vous auriez même pu avoir pire que ça.
Maux de tête : poudre de crâne humain.
Eczéma : pommade à la momie.
Un petit coup de fatigue :
du sirop de vipère.
Alors, sorcellerie ?
Magie ?
Médecine ?
Un petit peu ancienne, 300 ans,
mais un peu ancienne seulement, 300 ans :
l’arrière-grand-père
de l’arrière-grand-père
de votre arrière-grand-père.
Il a pu les utiliser, ces remèdes-là.
Pas si ancien que ça.
La vipère, prenons la vipère.
Je ne suis pas la seule
à avoir peur des serpents.
C'était le remède le plus réputé
pendant plus de 2000 ans.
L'entrée dans la composition
d'une panacée.
Une panacée,
c’est un médicament qui soigne tout.
Non seulement il soigne tout,
mais il évite de s’empoisonner
et il évite les incidents
liés aux animaux venimeux.
Ce remède, c'était la thériaque.
200 ingrédients.
Pierres précieuses.
Plantes.
Opium.
Vipère.
Dans l’Antiquité, il y avait un médecin
très réputé pour ça, c’est Gallien.
Pas n’importe qui,
c’était le médecin de Marc Aurèle.
Marc Aurèle adorait la thériaque,
il ne pouvait pas s’en passer.
Bien sûr, aujourd’hui, on se doute bien
qu’il y avait un peu d’opium dedans
et que ça devait aider.
Non seulement il y avait
des médicaments à base de vipère,
mais en plus, on pouvait s’en servir,
on pouvait manger de la vipère.
On va faire un petit saut dans le temps.
Madame de Sévigné, qui a dû passer
sa vie à écrire à sa fille.
Elle écrit un jour à sa fille
qu’elle ferait bien de prendre
un petit bouillon de vipère
parce qu’elle la trouve un peu fatiguée,
Madame de Grignan.
Et la recette sera donnée
par le frère de madame de Grignan.
Il connaît bien le bouillon de vipère.
Il le connaît bien parce qu’il a soigné
une maladie  vénérienne avec un an avant.
Alors, quand même compliqué,
de concilier un poison et un remède.
C’est juste ça la pharmacie.
Pharmacie, en grec, c’était pharmakon,
et c’est le poison ET le remède.
Ce qui ne nous dit pas pourquoi
utiliser de la vipère.
Il fallut attendre un moment
pour comprendre  ce qu’il y avait dedans.
Et on va revenir sur une controverse.
Là aussi, vous allez me dire
qu'elle est ancienne.
Nous sommes au 17e siècle,
alors je ne vais pas entrer
dans les détails parce que ça prend
deux gros dicos.
Sachez simplement qu'il y a deux camps.
Nous avons les Italiens, menés
par Francesco Redi.
Redi travaille avec une équipe
de collaborateurs
venus d’horizons différents
et vous allez voir
que ça a son importance.
De l’autre côté, nous avons les Français.
Les Français sont menés
par Moïse Charasse.
Et Charasse, lui,
il travaille avec ses élèves.
Il vaudrait peut-être mieux dire
avec ses disciples.
Le débat est simple.
Est-ce que le suc jaune contenu
dans la gencive de la vipère
est le venin responsable
des accidents liés aux morsures ?
Deux équipes qui font des expériences
qui se ressemblent.
On fait avaler du suc jaune
à des petits animaux.
Tout va bien, ils survivent.
Parfait.
On fait mordre des petits animaux
par des vipères.
Certains ont reçu de la thériaque,
puisque la thériaque est supposée
préserver des morsures de serpent,
d'autres non.
La plupart des animaux meurent,
mais pas tous.
Des deux côtés.
Les résultats concordent.
Les conclusions s'opposent.
Redi est catégorique :
le sucre jaune est l’unique responsable
des accidents liés aux morsures de vipère.
Charras est catégorique :
Le suc jaune est inoffensif.
Les accidents liés aux morsures
de vipère sont liés
«à ses esprits irrités».
La vipère se venge.
Dans les deux cas, rien ne s'explique.
Si le suc jaune est si dangereux,
comment se fait-il qu’on puisse
l’avaler sans danger ?
Si la vipère se venge,
comment se fait-il que tous les animaux
ne meurent pas ?
Bon, évidemment, aujourd'hui,
300 ans sont passés.
Pour nous, c'est très facile.
Il arrive que la vipère morde
sans injecter de venin.
Et le venin est inactivé
dans le tube digestif.
Aujourd’hui, il est très facile
de se gausser de Moïse Charas
et de ses esprits irrités.
On va se remettre
un petit peu dans le contexte.
Nous sommes au 17e siècle.
17e siècle, Molière,
on est exactement au moment
du Malade imaginaire.
On est trois ans avant la première
représentation du Malade imaginaire.
La médecine du 17ᵉ , elle est régie
par la théorie des humeurs.
Charas,
il baigne dans ce milieu-là.
Charas travaille avec ses élèves.
Les esprits irrités, c’est ce que Charas
a appris de ses maîtres
qui l’avaient  appris de leurs maîtres.
Redi, c’est un tout autre contexte.
Red, Il est médecin à la cour des Médicis,
ce qui lui assure déjà
un financement quasi illimité.
Mais surtout,
Il est membre de l’Accademia del Cimento.
L’Accademia del Cimento,
c’est une des premières
sociétés savantes d’Europe.
Elle réunit astronomes, artistes,
médecins, philosophes, physiciens…
Bouillonnement intellectuel.
Et c’est probablement cette situation
qui va permettre à Redi
de remettre en cause le dogme.
Aujourd’hui, on dirait
«questionner sa pratique».
Mais…
Il ne faut pas s’y tromper,
Charas et Redi étaient des savants,
étaient des scientifiques réputés,
des scientifiques renommés.
Aujourd’hui, ce seraient des personnalités
tout à fait marquantes,
ce seraient nos experts des plateaux télé.
Alors…
Pourquoi, mais pourquoi s’intéresser
à une controverse aussi vaine,
qui paraît complètement vaine en 2023 ?
Question souvent posée,
j’entends souvent : « À quoi ça te sert
de refaire des études d’histoire ? »
Alors, il y a un sous-entendu
assourdissant : « à ton âge. »
Alors il se trouve
que je suis guide nature.
Je suis assez bavarde et que j’adore
avoir des histoires à raconter
quand j’emmène les gens en balade.
Je le reconnais,
mais ce n’est pas la seule raison.
J'étais pharmacien, je suis pharmacien.
Ça implique des études austères.
J'ai ingurgité un paquet de connaissances.
Mais il y a une question
qui n'est jamais posée.
Comment on a conçu
des médicaments au début ?
Comment on les a imaginés ?
Puis il y a une autre question
qui se pose assez vite.
Tout ce que j’apprends, dans l’amphi,
est-ce que ce sera encore valable
dans trois ans ?
Dans trente ans ?
300 ans ?
Je peux vous dire qu’en 30 ans d’exercice,
des consensus et des recommandations,
j’en ai vu passer.
Vous vouez aux gémonies des pratiques
absolument sensées ou inversement,
validées, ce qui était une hérésie
dix ans plus tôt.
Ce Vidal,
une antiquité !
1967.
Une Bible, la Bible de la pharmacie.
Tous les médicaments,
pas tout à fait tous,
la plupart des médicaments qui sont
là-dedans n’existent plus aujourd’hui.
Pire que ça, ils nous font dresser
les cheveux sur la tête.
Celui-là est pas mal :
Mercaptomérine sodique Klein.
Combinaison d’un dérivé mercuriel
organique  du mercure.
Et ça soigne ?
l’obésité.
Mercure pour soigner de l’obésité.
Tout va bien.
Alors j’ai plongé quand même dans pas mal
de pharmacopées anciennes, des codex.
Je suis même tombée
sur un antidotaire, 1616.
Ce sont les recueils officiels,
les premiers recueils de formules
destinés aux médecins et aux apothicaires,
puis aux pharmaciens.
Ça permet de mesurer
deux choses :
que nous devons aux anciens,
et combien la médecine a évolué.
Et surtout, c’est en travaillant
dans un cadre, dans un tout autre cadre,
en suivant des cours
d’histoire de la médecine
qui sont dispensés par des historiens,
par des médecins,
mais aussi par des paléontologues,
des archéologues,
des hellénistes, des historiens de l’art
que je me suis rendue compte
du chemin parcouru.
Peut-être, c’est à ce moment-là
que j’ai abandonné le plus de certitudes,
j’ai pu remonter le temps,
que j’ai pu suivre le raisonnement de ceux
qui avait osé poser les questions
qui dérangeait,
et plus que tout, j’ai mesuré
l’importance des échanges
entre les disciplines,
entre les universités,
entre les courants de pensée.
Alors est-ce que c’était mieux avant ?
Je ne crois pas.
C'était différent, c'était très différent
et des progrès indéniables ont été faits.
Mais en médecine
comme dans les autres disciplines,
l’évolution n’est pas linéaire.
Et souvent, c’est en changeant
l’angle d’approche,
on peut…
se permettre d’abandonner un dogme
et permettre de franchir une étape.
Franchir une étape.
Ce n’est pas un aboutissement,
ce n’est pas une nouvelle
vérité intangible.
Et je vous assure que plonger
dans l’histoire des sciences en général
et celles de la médecine en particulier
est une grande source d’humilité.
Imaginez un petit peu :
que pensera
l’arrière-petit-fils
de l’arrière-petit-fils
de votre arrière-petit-fils
De la médecine de notre temps ?
(Applaudissements)